the Iranian football team's refusal to
sing their national anthem was bigger
news than the scoreline in their first
match but they were singing again ahead
of their two-nil win over Wales
following alleged pressure from the
government it is just one sign of the
huge risks Iranian people are taking to
show their descent at a World Cup
increasingly overshadowed by human
rights issues
these Iranian fans in the stadium wanted
to Cease the opportunity and draw
attention to the bloody Crackdown on
protests happening in their home country
but their message women life Freedom was
not welcomed by FIFA and Qatar and
removed just like Iranian Flags altered
to hide the symbol of the Islamic
Republic
[Applause]
the team's decision to this time sing
the national anthem albeit reluctantly a
sign of the immense pressure the players
are under and the humiliation painful to
watch for many in attendance
for others it's a symbol of giving into
a regime they don't approve of
especially since it comes just a day
after their former teammate Warrior
refuri was arrested in Iran after a
training session with his Club fulat
josestar
therefore he is of Kurdish origin and
has repeatedly criticized the oppression
of women and minorities in the Islamic
Republic
now he's facing charges for tarnishing
the reputation of the national team and
spreading propaganda against the state
that makes refori one of the more than
15 000 people authorities in Iran have
arrested since the protest began in
September
more than 300 Iranians have been killed
according to human rights groups and
every day Security Forces attack
protesters all over the country
it has created a rift through Iranian
Society that's also on display in Qatar
outside the stadium supporters of the
Islamic Republic try to silence
anti-government protesters and hide
their messages
turning the match itself into a sideshow
and so the Iranian team managed to
defeat Wales on the pitch and yet
disappointed many of their fans for not
standing by them
Iranians are not limiting their protests
to stadiums and Qatar demonstrations
continue in Iran with several taking
place in Tehran and other cities on
Saturday that's according to Social
Media activists say Security Forces
opened fire on a crowd gathered in the
city of assadan in the Southeast after
Friday prayers dozens of feared dead or
wounded in a speech on Saturday Iran's
supreme leader Ayatollah Ali Khamenei
praised the bastillege Malaysia militia
that have been at the heart of the
government Crackdown
to get more on the story we're now
joined by yalda sarbach head of our DW
person service yalda good to have you
with us
um so kamenes or Harmony speech came
just a day after another alleged
Crackdown in sahadan and and also the
win of the national team in Qatar that's
quite a mixed bag of feelings Joy he is
suffering there how is that perceived in
the country
how it is perceived is that the part of
joy that you mentioned we don't at the
moment the pictures that we see within
Iran are the security forces are the
Revolutionary guard Corps who are
actually
um celebrating the win of the national
team who are
um who are on their tanks from which
they they've been killing people on the
streets dancing and celebrating and of
course
um many people as we've seen the report
has shown it very well
um many Iranians are actually
um frustrated and are turning their
backs on the national team because they
were expecting them to speak out as many
other athletes and also other football
players within Iran have been doing
this change of heart that we've seen now
singing along the national anthem could
this have something to do with uh we saw
in this report a famous Iranian football
player getting arrested earlier this
week uh why now why during the World Cup
in Qatar when the whole world is
watching
it it has two sides to it on one hand
has been very outspoken even before so
he was he's always been very critique to
the criticizing the regime
um for human rights violations for many
more he has been a former player of the
national team
um he has been a player of the of Tehran
Esther Cloud's team he has been kicked
out for because he has been so outspoken
um and now of course it is also a signal
to the to the team the national team a
signal of intimidation kind of showing
you know this could also happen to you
if you don't behave
um the way we want in Qatar but on the
other hand
um we can also see that many people at
least saying that for being part of the
national team you have to also be away
loyal to the system and to the regime so
that's why also people like ruia referee
are not taking part there right right
and yelda just briefly if you would
because we are seeing the more More
protest symbols against the Iranian
regime are now banned from the stadiums
in Qatar uh is everybody there being
silenced now
um this is very crucial what we're
witnessing right now in Qatar because on
the one hand the Iranian regime is
mobilizing his people and supporters to
go to go to support the team to give
interviews to you know to show the world
how uh how women are treated equally in
Iran and have the same rights for
instance and on the other hand
um we are Qatar is helping to silence
um protesters to enter with the with
banners women life Freedom even with
t-shirts uh where it says women life
freedom on it and we know about Iranian
journalists actually who were before the
before the World Cup would start who
were getting threats by the Iranian
intelligence
um that if you will come to Qatar to
report
um you will be facing us kind of showing
that also the relation in the support of
Qatar with the Iranian regime and we
have also Avengers right now indoor
trying to raise these questions and
being silenced when they ask about
uhuria referee when they asked their the
national team we have state reporters
from Iranian television uh Europe who
are then protesting against uh reporters
who are trying to raise these questions
all right
head of our DW Persian service thank you
so much Hilda